and lucas g lito will take the ball at
home for the first time since june the
29th lucas ciolido a former all-star
a little bit of a struggle this year for
him see his pitch usage four-seam
fastball he pitches mostly up with that
his changeup is his best secondary pitch
and if he can throw his slider and
curveball over nobody has done much
against it this year
oncotta about a step behind the bag
third a little off the line
2-0 swung on popped up off into foul
territory mankind is going to take a
look at it over by the white sox bench
and puts it away for out number one
2-2 delivery
and that's lying down the right field
line and it's down for a base hit and
will get all the way to the wall
brantley tearing for second as sheets
digs it out of the corner and it is a
one-out double for brantley who is now
six for 11 in his career against giolito
the 1-1
and that's hammered pretty deep to left
but it's playable for vaughn backing up
a couple of steps shy of the track makes
the catch
[Applause]
this a fly ball into shallow left and a
good job by giolito to work around the
brantley double jake odorizzi who had a
rough and slow start to the season and
has been rocked solid his last five or
six hours well since he came off the il
he has been really good 2.29 era to 1.
he's lifted deep to right field ranging
back kyle tucker all the way to the
warning track and will flag it down
here's the payoff pitch and that's a
ground ball left side only infielder on
that side is toro he feels it at the
shortstop spot and throws out mankata
and an o2
punched on the ground to correa
he'll lead off the astros second
here's the 1-1
fly ball to center field in comes brian
goodwin he should have this one easily
and does catches it shoulder high
another two strike offering to tucker
who tried to hold back but the home
plate umpire brian knight says that he
went around and there is the first
geolito strikeout of the night
[Applause]
the 1-0's lifted into center brian
goodwin will take a couple of steps in
and put it away brian goodwin at second
base and leori garcia at first after a
walk it'll bring up andrew vaughn 1-0
that's it
high pretty deep to right center but
it's going to be playable for straw to
his left he makes the catch both runners
tagging the throw in by straw to second
and it is in time to get garcia boy poor
scouting report for the white sox
running on straw
with the trail runner i can't believe he
continued to go i thought he was just
going to fake it
but a strike by straw and a big double
play that's huge
sheets punches it on the ground to toro
and that'll do it for the white sox
here's a 2-2
cut and a miss castro just goes down
swing it 1-2 swung on lifted into left
vaughn takes a couple of steps in then
re-adjusts he'll settle under this one
for out number two
the o2 a soft swing and a soft serve at
the center goodwin's got it
three up three down it'll bring up zach
collins the white sox backstop
zach collins puts a charge into one the
other way deep drive to the wall and
gone
fourth of the year for collins and just
like the previous three it gives the
white sox a lead collins gets a splitter
up not a terrible pitch but you see he
barrels it stays behind the ball
and the ball is flying
so tim anderson steps in now with that
hit streak at 13. what has he learned
from that bat
first offer is pounded into right center
field back goes tucker he's at the wall
and it's back to back home runs for the
white sox that one bouncing off the very
top of the yellow stripe in right field
and then continued on into the bullpen
sheets the other way well struck to left
field back to the wall and it's off the
wall bradley couldn't make the play
straw there to back it up and it's a
double for gavin sheets
here is the aforementioned burger
struck out his first time up on an
elevated fastball
lifted towards the cap and left center
field and down and for jake berger it'll
be a second career major league rbi it
gives the sox a three nothing lead as
sheet scores from second anderson with
his offensive field homer his last time
up the first pitch tim anderson laced
into right passed past altuve at second
base
burgers on his horse he will score the
white sox lead at four to nothing so
bases loaded now for the white sox and a
chance to really crack things open big
gap in left center field for goodwin but
good win with a liner but right to
altuve and the light sox leave them
loaded in the fourth sheets with a
double in the fourth scored iran on a
jake burger double right after
drives one into center field back goes
straw this ball is gone two run home run
for gavin sheets his fourth of the
season and the white sox lead the astros
six to nothing bottom five
oh that's big power right there by gavin
he went down and it seemed like he was
hitting with a one iron that was a
missile
[Applause]
swinging away there's hamilton tested
early he's caught up by goodwin my
goodness
and a smile on hamilton's face
goodwin cut him off in the outfield for
that that's not the first time that's
happened in a white sox outfield in the
last couple of years
here he comes on the one-two
chopper to third moncada's got it throw
over to first gets him
first pitch lined into left field and
down tim's gonna make the big turn
around first base he'll get into second
base easily
double single home run oh my you know
what that means just a triple away from
a cycle
bravo the former and reigning mvp
sitting at 213 career home runs
built it into laughs this ball is gone
jose abreu with a three-run shot
and the white sox lead
nine
nothing and that one has just tied it
with carlton fisk on the all-time white
sox charts with 2 14.
giolito has retired 18 of the 19 astros
he has faced
and he goes down swinging
popped up behind home plate collins is
going to give it a chase toward the on
deck circle for the astros and he
catches it basket move
shelito comes home ball popped up
finds second base tim anderson can't
find it he's gonna have to take a run
and will eventually get to it
burger tonight an rbi double he's one
for three struck out and grounded out
deep to left his first big league home
run
it's jake berger to go up 10 to nothing
[Applause]
toro goes the other way deep to left
vaughn ranging back at the track and
houston's on the board
abraham toro with his fourth home run of
the year in just 29 games breaks up the
shutout
lucas giolito is looking to add his
exclamation mark to the night he's going
for a complete game back out for the
night of the game
straw hard hit to center to his
counterpart hamilton one down
he struck him out
eight strikeouts for gia leno he's one
out away from a complete game
popped up
garcia and abreu over garcia's got it
and a sparkling sterling gem of a
performance in a complete game by lucas
giolino